The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: What I thought I
would do today is two things.
I wanted to give this talk
about osteochondral scaffolds,
and this is just slides.
I'm not going to
write anything down.
So there aren't going
to be any notes.
And I'll put the slides on the
Stellar site, I don't know,
this afternoon or
tonight or something.
And this isn't going to take
the whole time we have today,
so the other thing
I thought I'd do
is I wanted to walk you
through this little booklet
that I handed out about
how to write a paper.
So this is by Mike
Ashby, who you know,
I've written books with.
He was my PhD advisor
and we wrote the books
on cellular solids together.
He has written many books.
I looked him up on
Amazon this morning,
and even though I know
he'd written many books,
I was shocked how many books.
They had 58 listings for just
books with him as a co-author
and some are second
editions and third editions.
He's written a lot of books.
He's written a lot
of materials, papers.
And he's, in the
materials community,
he's seen as a very
clear and lucid writer.
So he's written this
thing for his students
and I thought we could
just walk through it
and I can talk to you a
little bit about writing.
Because I know you're not
quite there with your projects,
but later on in the
term you're going
to want to write
up your project,
and it's not too early to
start thinking about writing.
And there's some really
good advice and it's short
and it's to the point.
It's really helpful,
that little brochure.
So we won't read
every single thing,
but I wanted to kind
of walk through some
of the main points in
it, and that pretty much
should take the hour.
So last time we talked about
tissue engineering scaffolds,
and today, I wanted
to do a case study,
and this was a
project we had here
at MIT and in collaboration with
some people in the materials
department at
Cambridge University.
And we made what we called
an osteochondral scaffold.
So osteo means there was
a part for regenerating
bone and chondral means there
was a part for regenerating
cartilage.
And really the point
of the scaffold
was to try to repair small
defects in cartilage.
And I'll explain why we
did the bone thing as well.
So this is just
a little outline.
I'm going to talk a
little bit about what
the structure of cartilage is.
We have a little
schematic of that.
Then talk about how small
defects in cartilage
are currently treated.
So these are things that,
say you're an athlete,
you might tear some
cartilage, that kind of thing,
not like you have osteoarthritis
and you need a new knee.
It's not going to do that.
So I'll talk a little
bit about cartilage
and the current treatments.
I'll talk about
some of the things
we thought about in making
an osteochondral scaffold,
like what parameters
were important.
And we based it on that
collagen-GAG scaffold
that I talked about last time.
So the collagen
glycoseaminoglycan
scaffold that we
talked about last time.
And what we did
was we had a layer
that was a collagen based
scaffold for the cartilage
and we had another
layer that was
a mineralized version of that.
And one of the main things
we did in this project
was figure out how to
mineralize that scaffold.
And then we made this two-layer
osteochondral scaffold.
So I'll talk about that, OK?
So are we good?
So this is a schematic
of articular cartilage.
Articular just means it's
in a joint, so between
like, say, two of
your long bones,
and there's several regions.
So this shows both the cartilage
and the bone underneath it.
And so this top layer is
called the superficial layer,
and then there's
a transition zone,
and then there's this
deep cartilage here.
And the little white lines
represent how the collagen
is oriented in the cartilage.
So the collagen is
oriented, more or less,
vertically here and then it
becomes more kind of woven
and horizontal towards the top.
And so those three
different zones,
the collagen is
oriented differently.
Then there's a region down
here called the tidemark.
Everything above here is just
cartilage and everything below
is calcified to some extent.
So this next layer down here
it's more cartilage-like,
but it's got some
calcification in it as well.
And then here's
the compact bone.
They call it subchondral bone.
It's the bone below
the cartilage.
So chondral is cartilage.
And then here's the
trabecular bone.
We talked about trabecular
bone a couple of weeks ago, OK?
So one of the things is there's
different types of collagen
and the different types may
have slightly different fiber
structures or slightly
different compositions.
They're all related, but they're
slightly different types.
And bone has what's called
type I collagen and cartilage
has type II collagen. So
when we made the scaffold,
we wanted the bony
layer to be made
with type I and the cartilage
layer to be made with type II.
So I think with the 3032
people have probably seen it.
I think I did a
version of this for you
guys, didn't I at the
end of term, something?
Yeah, but there's other people,
so it's really for them.
So if you think of
articular cartilage,
it has difficulty repairing
itself and one of the reasons
that it's difficult
for the cartilage
to repair itself is that
there's no blood supply in it
and another reason is that
there's not very many cells.
So chondrocytes are
the cells in cartilage
and if there's a low volume
fraction of the cells,
then it's not so easy for
that small number of cells
to actually produce the
extracellular matrix, which
is kind of what you think
of as the cartilage.
And it can be damaged, either
as I said, from sports injuries,
typically that's what
young people get,
they tear their cartilage in
some sporting injury accident,
or from osteoarthritis.
So these scaffolds
we're talking about,
they're not really meant
to repair large amounts
of cartilage that are damaged.
And as I said, the cartilage
has a poor capacity
for self-repair.
So there's several
treatments, there's
three treatments that
are given currently
and the most common one is
called marrow stimulation.
And some of these
orthopedic treatments
are fairly crude
when you look at it.
So this marrow stimulation,
what's involved
is they take a drill.
So here's the drill.
And they basically drill
through the cartilage.
So this would be the
cartilage layer here.
And they drill
down into the bone
and they want to get down
into the trabecular bone.
So they want to go
below the cortical
or the subchondral bone
and they want to go down
into the trabecular bone.
And the reason they want to
do that is the trabecular bone
has bone marrow in it
and the bone marrow
has mesenchymal
stem cells, and they
want those mesenchymal
stem cells to move up
into the cartilage layer.
So that's what this
red glob is here.
The idea is that
you've made a hole
and now that hole
is going to fill up
with a blood clot, which will
have these mesenchymal stem
cells, and that those
will form cartilage.
So it does work to some
extent, but it's not really
a great result. There's
something like 75,000
of these done a year.
As I said, this is the
most common kind of repair.
The next most sophisticated
type of repair, what they do
is they take plugs of bone and
cartilage from another place.
So say this is
where the defect is
and they want to repair that.
They take bone and cartilage
from this spot up here.
So they sort of drill out
little cylindrical cores
and then they plug them
into this bit here.
And that's called an
osteochondral autograft.
Sometimes it's
called mosaicplasty
because they build up a
little mosaic from all
those little pieces.
And then they just
leave these donor sites,
where they took the plugs from,
they just leave those empty.
So they try to take the bone
and cartilage from regions where
the loads are lower,
but they end up
leaving holes, which
is not so desirable.
And again, those holes
may fill a little bit
by the previous mechanism.
Then the most fancy
method that they use now
is called autologous
chondrocyte implantation.
So what they do is they
harvest cartilage cells
from the patient.
They then take them to a
lab and they culture them
for two or three
weeks and they get
them to multiply and
proliferate and grow
and then they
re-implant the cells.
So this works fairly
well, but the difficulty
is it involves two surgeries,
so one to get the cells out
and one to put them
back in, and there's
the cost of the cell culture.
So this is a much more expensive
procedure because of the two
surgeries and the cost of
doing the cell culture,
but I think it's the
method that works the best.
And when I talked about this in
3032, I mentioned Dara Torres.
Dara Torres is an
Olympic swimmer.
She's 47.
She began swimming
in the Olympics
in 1984, more than 30 years ago.
And she has swum
in the Olympics,
not every one,
but up until 2008.
And even 2008, she won
three silvers that year.
She was, I think,
the oldest person
who's ever won a
medal in the Olympics.
And she had this surgery done
at the Brigham a few years ago.
And it used to be,
they've stopped
running these commercials
but the Brigham for a time
was running these commercials,
that featured Dara Torres
and saying basically that she
had this surgery done there.
I'm assuming she
was happy with it.
OK, so that's what
they do currently
and what we were thinking of and
what other groups have thought
about is could you repair
damage in the cartilage
by using a tissue
engineering scaffold?
So what we were
thinking about when
we tried to do
this project was we
wanted to use a healthy
articular cartilage joint
as a model for our scaffold.
We wanted to have a layer that
would go down into the bone
so that you would have access
to those mesenchymal stem cells.
And that's why we wanted
an osteochondral scaffold,
so that we would have a
layer for the cartilage
but also a layer that would
go down into the bone.
We wanted to be able to control
scaffold parameters, things
like the mineral content
and the pore size.
Remember, I said these
tissue engineering scaffolds,
the pore size is one
of the parameters,
that you want to have the
pore size in a certain range.
And we wanted to
use materials that
would be appropriate
for approval
from things like the FDA.
So typically, when people make
tissue engineering scaffolds,
they don't start with
some material that's
never been approved before.
They start with
something that already
has approval for
something else and that's
what we wanted to do too.
So this was our idea of
what we wanted the scaffold
to look like.
We wanted an unmineralized type
II collagen scaffold up here
that would be for the cartilage.
We wanted a mineralized type
I collagen scaffold down there
for the bone.
And we wanted some
region that had
some gradient in
mineralization because it
would be like that
layer of cartilage that
was slightly mineralized.
So we wanted to duplicate
that whole structure.
So that was our picture
of what we wanted to do
and we had a pretty good idea of
how we were going to make this.
We were just going to
use that same process
that [INAUDIBLE] developed
for the skin scaffolds.
He was involved
with this project
but just used type II
collagen instead of type I.
The challenge was
really figuring out
how to make the mineralized
collagen scaffold
and then how to get this
gradient in the mineralization
between the two layers.
So this, I think, I
showed you last time.
So this is just the
method we used to make
the collagen-GAG scaffold.
So we take type II collagen.
We put it in acetic acid.
Remember, that destroys
the periodic banding
of the collagen and it improves
the immunological response.
We add the chondroitin
6-sulfate, the GAG,
to crosslink it.
We then just make a
slurry out of that.
So we mix that all together.
We keep it as a slurry.
And then the second
stage is you put
the slurry or the
suspension into a pan,
and then you do the
freeze drying process.
So you go through
this process where
you start at this
room temperature
and atmospheric pressure.
You cool it down to freeze
it, and then you sublimate it,
and you're left with a very
porous collagen-GAG scaffold.
So these are pictures.
I think this was with
a type I collagen,
but it looks the same
with the type II collagen.
So that's what the
structure looks like.
I think I showed
you this last time.
We can control the pore
size by controlling
the freezing temperature.
So the way the
freeze dryer works
is there is shelves that
you put these pans on,
and these cooling elements
go through the shelves,
and you can set the
temperature of those shelves.
So we would set the
temperature of those shelves
to different values and we
got different pore sizes.
So the colder the
shelf temperature
was, the faster the
freezing, and the smaller
the size of the ice
grains, and then
the smaller the
size of the pores.
And this is just the
mechanical response again.
So we did mechanical
tests on it.
These are some of the
numbers for the properties.
So we tested it
dry and wet, and we
measured a modulus and a
buckling collapse stress
for it.
So those are just
some values there.
And then it came to making
the mineralized collagen-GAG
scaffold, and one of the
students in Cambridge, England
was really the main person
who did this, Andrew Lynn.
And he worked with
Brendan Harley, who
was our student here,
and after they graduated,
I had another student,
Biraja Kanungo,
who worked on this too.
So Andrew Lynn really
developed this technique.
And this involved taking
the collagen and the GAG, so
the same as for
the other scaffold,
but this time, if we want to
make a mineralized scaffold,
we somehow have to get
calcium phosphate into it.
So it's got to have sort of
a hydroxyapatite-ish type
of component to it.
So this time we used phosphoric
acid instead of the acetic acid
and we put some calcium salts
into the mixture as well.
And Andrew was really the one
who figured out how to do this
and what salts to use.
And then the process
was very similar.
So we have this slurry.
We mix the slurry up.
We did a freeze drying
process, and then we
crosslinked it with a chemical
crosslinker called EDAC.
So it's just a chemical
that you put into this
and it crosslinks it all.
So that was how we made
the mineralized scaffold.
The mineral we got was
something called brushite,
which is a calcium phosphate,
but it's not exactly
the same as hydroxyapatite.
And we could control
the amount of brushite
by different weight
fractions or volume fractions
by controlling how much of
the calcium salts we put in
and what the molarity of
the phosphoric acid was.
If you take brushite
and you put it in water,
it then converts to
octacalcium phosphate
and then to apatite by
a hydrolytic conversion.
So the apatite is related to
the hydroxyapatite in bone.
And this was the structure
of the mineralized scaffold
that we got.
So you can see it looks
a little different
from the collagen-GAG scaffold.
It's much denser.
Typically, the densities
were like 5% or 10% dense.
And remember, the collagen
scaffold was 0.5% dense.
So it's a lot denser.
But if you notice, there's
a few things to notice here.
So one is the pore size,
that's a 500 micron bar.
And we could make pores between
about 50 and 1,000 microns,
depending on the
freezing conditions.
And the range of pore
sizes we were shooting for
was somewhere
between 100 and 500,
so we could get in the
right ballpark with that.
And you can see, just
looking at that picture,
if that's 500
microns, those pores
are somewhere of that order.
Another thing to look
at is this image here,
and this just shows,
the white little dots
are the calcium
phosphate mineral,
and it just shows
that the mineral
is uniformly distributed
throughout the thickness
of the scaffold.
So some people had tried to make
scaffolds for regenerating bone
where they take, say,
one of those polymers
for resorbable sutures
or they take collagen
and they coat it
with hydroxyapatite,
but the shortcoming of that
is that the scaffold is
going to resorb over time.
The cells are going to secrete
enzymes, which are going
to eat away at the scaffold.
And if the scaffold
resorbs, you're
eating away at the
hydroxyapatite first
and then you're
left with whatever
polymer is underneath that.
Whereas this gives you a
more uniform composition
throughout the thickness
of the scaffold,
and you've got calcium
phosphate everywhere
throughout the thickness of
the struts in the scaffold.
So that's the structure of that.
We wanted to make sure that
the mineral was uniformly
distributed throughout
the scaffold,
and we did some micro-CT
imaging, some micro computer
tomography.
And this is our sample
here, and this red line just
says that is the plane at
which this image was taken,
and the black is the mineral.
And then here's a lower plane
and here's another image.
And you can see the calcium
phosphate's pretty uniformly
distributed throughout
that specimen there.
And this was just another way of
looking at the same thing using
EDX in an SEM to look
at where the calcium was
and where the phosphate was.
So again, this is uniform
distribution of the mineral.
We did mechanical tests
on these scaffold as well.
So we measured moduli
and collapse stresses.
We get the same kind of
stress strain curve as all
these other cellular solids.
This was done by-
Biraja Kanungo was
the student who did this bit.
One of the things
we found was that
with these mineralized
scaffolds you
could manually compress them.
If you pushed them down
and you hydrated them,
they would recover
all the deformation,
but we were increased
in improving
the mechanical properties
of the mineralized scaffold
for improved handling
during surgery.
And there's another reason
that I'll get to as well.
So the second reason
is that, if you
look at how bone
itself forms, it
forms from a collagen
precursor, so bone in your body.
And there's something
called osteoid,
which is this collagen-based
precursor to bone,
and it has a modulus of
about 25 to 40 kilopascals
and Angler showed that if you
have mesenchymal stem cells
and you put them on substrates
of different stiffnesses,
they differentiate into
different kinds of cells,
depending on the stiffness
of the substrate.
So the substrate stiffness
can affect what kind of cells
you get.
And the idea here
was we thought, well,
if we could get a stiffness that
was close to this osteoid, what
the natural bone
formation has, then
that might help the
mesenchymal stem
cells differentiate
into the bony cells
that we want them to.
So we wanted to try to
reach a stiffness of this
in the wet state.
And if I back up here,
you can see the stiffness
we had was around four in the
wet state, four kilopascals
and we want to get to 30
or 40, something like that.
So these are our
equations for the modeling
of the mineralized scaffold,
the open celled foam
models for the modulus and
for the collapse strength.
So we could change
different things.
We could change the
solid properties
or we could change
the relative density.
The geometry of the
thing is probably not
going to help us too much.
So basically,
that's what we did.
We first started off trying to
increase the mineral content.
We thought if there was
more mineral content that
would make it stiffer.
So Biraja made these more highly
mineralized scaffolds and these
are just some SEM
images of those.
But the thing he found was
that the properties actually
got worse when he had the more
highly mineralized scaffold.
The modulus went down and
the strength went down,
so that wasn't very helpful.
And when he looked
into it more detail,
he found that he had more
voids in the cell walls
and he had more
disconnected walls.
This shows some of
the micrographs,
so this isn't really
very quantitative,
but you can see
there's holes here.
There's a few holes
here, but there
tended to be a bigger volume
fraction of holes in the more
highly mineralized scaffolds
and more walls that
were disconnected.
So we realized increasing
the mineral content wasn't
going to work very well.
And then the second
thing he tried
was increasing the
relative density.
So we started off at this
density of 4 1/2% dense and he
developed a method of increasing
the relative density up
to about almost 20% here.
He did this by, first
of all, he tried
to just mix more
of the constituents
into the slurry, that's kind
of the most obvious thing.
But as you add
more constituents,
it gets harder and harder
to mix the thing up and have
it homogeneously distributed.
So in the end, that's not
how he made these things.
He started with the
starting mixture
and then he had a vacuum system
for sucking water out of it.
So he would reduce
the amount of water,
which essentially increased
the amount of solids
that was in there.
And you can see in
this last one here,
the most dense
scaffold, he was sucking
the water in one
direction, and he sucked it
so much that he was starting
to get the cells collapsing.
So this one here,
these cells that
have this sort of elongated
orientation, that's
because the cells are
starting to collapse
because of the vacuum
that he was applying.
But he could get a
pretty good difference.
This was almost 5%.
That's almost 20%, so
roughly a factor of four.
There are, yeah, four
difference between them.
So then he did
mechanical tests too,
and he measured the
relative density.
Here's the moduli wet
and then the strength dry
and the strength wet.
So you can see here, if
you look at the dry moduli,
for instance, when you go
from this relative density
to that relative density,
from about 14% to 19%,
the modulus actually drops down.
And if you look at the
structure, I think,
it's because you've got this
flattened structure here.
You've collapsed the
cells a bit already.
So there's a maximum
density that you
might want to go to, probably
somewhere around 14% or 15%.
But the wet modulus
we've got here
is around 35 kilopascals, so
that's close to the target
that we had.
It's close to what
we wanted to have.
So one way you
could get the right
or the appropriate modulus
is by increasing the density
to that value.
Another way is by playing
around with the crosslinking.
So those values were for
non-crosslinked scaffolds.
So here, this is the 14% dense
scaffold wet, non-crosslinked
it was around 35 kilopascals.
This is a dehydrothermal
treatment,
just basically heating it up.
It gives you a higher modulus.
And then this is a chemical
crosslinking technique that
increases the modulus again.
So if you put all
of this together,
you can show these results
for the modulus on one table.
So these are all
the wet modulus.
So it's pretty clear
by playing around
with the relative density
and the crosslinking,
that you can get a
scaffold in that range.
And the idea is that that would
help get the mesenchymal stem
cells to differentiate into
these osteoblast-like cells.
So then we wanted to
also see if our models
for the cellular solids could
be applied to this scaffold,
and we needed the
solid properties.
So Kristyn Van Vliet
helped us with this,
and we isolated a single strut,
bonded it to a glass slide,
and, I think, I
mentioned this last time,
we used an AFM tip to then
do a little bending test.
So I think the one I
mentioned last time was
for the collagen-GAG scaffold.
Then we also did the same thing
for the mineralized scaffold.
And here we measured a modulus
of about seven gigapascals,
so that's a dry modulus.
And just for
comparison, the modulus
of the solid and trabecular
bone is something around 18.
So it's lower, but it's
in the same ballpark.
And by nanoindentation,
we measured a strength
of about 200, and that's
similar to what you
would get in trabecular bone.
So the solid in the
struts themselves
is not exactly like trabecular
bone in mechanical properties,
but not too far off.
And then here's a plot of
the scaffold modulus divided
by the solid modulus against
the relative density.
And this line here, the curve,
is a squared relationship.
So that's what we'd expect
for the foam models.
And this is the strength.
These things fail by a
plastic or a brittle failure,
and this curve is a three halves
power with relative density.
And again, that's what you'd
expect from the cellular solids
model.
So that gives you a
reasonable description
of the behavior of the
mineralized scaffold.
So again, these were
the considerations
in trying to make the
osteochondral scaffold.
So now we have a
collagen scaffold
and we have a
mineralized scaffolding,
and we want to put the
two of them together.
So we wanted to use
the joint as a model,
and we wanted to have some
intermediate layer that
had some gradation in
the mineralization.
So that was the next step.
And the way we did
that was we used
what we fancily called
liquid-phase co-synthesis.
This just meant that we took
the mineralized collagen-GAG
slurry, we poured
that into a mold,
and then we poured the
non-mineralized slurry
into the same mold.
And then we just allowed the
two slurries to interdiffuse
for some time period.
And then we did the
freeze drying step.
So the idea was, that if
you poured the one on top
of the other, the
mineralized one is denser
and then you put the
less dense one on top,
but over some period
of time, there will be
some diffusion between the two.
And then we just did
the freeze drying step.
So this is the scaffold
we ended up with.
This is a micro computer
tomography image.
So here's the
collagen-GAG scaffold
for the cartilage
on top, and here's
the mineralized collagen-GAG
calcium phosphate scaffold
on the bottom for the bone.
And that just kind of
shows what it looked like.
The porosities
and the pore sizes
we got, the collagen-GAG
was about 98% porous
and had a pore size
of around 650 microns.
The mineralized scaffold
was 95.5% porous
and had a pore size of
400, roughly, microns.
And then this is
what the structure
looked like in the EDX.
You can see, this is
the collagen-GAG layer,
this is the mineralized
layer, and there's
some zone in between that's
a little bit mineralized, not
as much as the bony layer
but more than the cartilage
layer, and the same
with the phosphorus.
So we have this collagen-GAG
slightly mineralized layer,
and then a more
mineralized layer
And then finally, there was
a student, Scott Vickers,
who worked with Myron
Spector at the Brigham.
And oops, oops.
No, I don't want the
weekly updates, thank you.
Sorry.
Well, let me just
get rid of this.
Oop, where's my
little mousy mouse?
There we go.
OK, so Scott Vickers
worked with Myron Spector,
and Myron had a surgeon who
could do animal studies.
So we did some animal
studies on goats.
I think there were six
goats at the Brigham.
And they took a plug out
of the knee of the goats,
and they put our scaffold in.
So this is one of the
surgeries as they're
about to poke the scaffold in.
And then, Scott waited, I
think it was four months,
and then sacrificed the goats,
and then did the histology.
And this is one of the
images from his PhD.
So this staining shows that
you've got tissue growing in.
The scaffold was where these
little black dotted lines are.
So you had bony tissue
in here, and there
was a cartilage-like
tissue formed at the top.
It wasn't perfect
articular cartilage,
but it was something
similar to that.
And really was as far as we took
the project with the funding
that we had.
We had a-- I don't know if
you remember that-- well, it's
beyond before your time.
But Cambridge and MIT had a
big research collaboration
and the student exchange
was part of that.
And this was done through
that research collaboration
between Cambridge and MIT.
So this was as far as we took
it with that research funding.
Andrew Lynn, who was the
student in Cambridge,
who developed the
mineralized scaffold,
he then started up a company
called Orthomimetics,
and he had longer term
animal studies done,
and he took it a little further.
In Europe, there's something
called CE Mark approval,
and CE Mark approval
means you can
start doing clinical trials.
So he never got FDA
approval for it,
but he got approval to have
clinical trials in Europe.
And the first clinical use
was in February of 2009.
And they started off
using it for the donor
sites for the mosaicplasties.
Remember the second
method I talked about?
They take plugs
out of one region
and put them into the
region with the damage.
So what they were doing
was using our scaffold
to fill up these
donor sites here
and they found that
worked quite well.
And then eventually,
they started using it
for the primary sites as well.
And as of about April a
few years ago, April 2012,
they had treated about
200 people with this.
AUDIENCE: Wait, so why not
just directly start putting it
in the-- why start with the--
LORNA GIBSON: I think
because these were supposed
to be sites that were less
loaded, weren't as highly
stressed, and they thought that
was a more, not as critical
a place to put them in.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what is
different about this scaffold?
Is it the lack of
the dense bone that
allows all of the marrow cells
to migrate up to the cartilage?
LORNA GIBSON: Well,
I think, there's not
that many people that have
made osteochondral scaffolds,
so it's good that we've
got these two layers.
And the idea that you try
to get the stem cells up
into the cartilage.
The stem cells
will differentiate
into the bone or
the cartilage, I
think, partly depending on the
stiffness of the surrounding
tissue.
AUDIENCE: But they don't do
that in normal bone because
of the dense layer?
LORNA GIBSON: No,
I think they would.
But the thing is, I
mean, in some ways,
that very first
technique where you just
drill holes in, I mean, in some
ways, that's what it's counting
on, right, is that the
marrow mesenchymal stem
cells are going to differentiate
either into the bone
or into the cartilage.
But it's just got a hole
to differentiate into.
So this gives the cell
something to attach
to and I think, gives
a better result. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is part of
the scaffold and this bone,
are they removing
the original bone?
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah,
they remove-- yeah.
Let me back up a step.
So when they do this thing
here, so this is in a goat,
but they would do the
same thing in a person.
So when they drill the
hole to put that in, they
go through the cartilage, they
go through the compact bone,
the dense bone, and they go
into the trabecular bone,
because you don't really
get into the marrow
until you're in the pores
of the trabecular bone.
OK?
Are we good?
AUDIENCE: How do they attach it?
LORNA GIBSON: How
do they attach it?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LORNA GIBSON: I think
it's just a press fit.
I think they just drill
a hole and stick it in.
And these are all
in joints, right?
So there's always another
bone pressing against it.
I mean, in the surgery,
they kind of peel things
apart so they can do the
surgery but there's another bone
pressing down on it.
So I don't think there
was any glue or anything.
So there's that.
So this is just a summary.
So we were able to make
this two-layer scaffold
with a gradient
interface, and we
tried to make it
so that it mimicked
the osteochondral tissues.
And this freeze
drawing process allowed
us to control things
like the mineral content,
the porosity, the pore sizes.
And then we used materials
that had already been
approved for medical devices.
And this was funded
by a number of places.
So the Cambridge MIT Institute
was that collaboration
I mentioned.
I have a chair and I
used some money for that.
Brendan Harley was one
of the students involved
and he got a
fellowship from MIT.
And Andrew Lynn got a
fellowship through the Cambridge
Commonwealth Trust and
through St. John's College
in Cambridge, that's
his college there.
So he had had
funding through that.
So I think that's
the end of that talk.
So are we good with scaffolds?
Yeah, you're good?
So obviously, this
probably whole course
is on tissue engineering.
This is just
scratching the surface
and giving you an
introduction to it,
but I wanted to show you
how a lot of these scaffolds
look a lot like the foamy
materials that I work on,
and that you can use the
same models for trying
to understand the mechanical
properties of the scaffold.
And even though the scaffolds
are acting in a biological way,
there's actually a connection
between the mechanical behavior
of the scaffolds and
the biological response.
So I'm going to talk on
Monday about cell/scaffold
interactions, so
how the environment
biological cells are in
can affect how they behave.
So we're going to talk about
things like cell adhesion
and cell migration
and cell contraction,
contractile behavior.
So I've got another talk
a little bit like this
and that means I'll
have a few notes I'll
put on the board
on Monday about how
the environment that the cells
are in affects how they behave,
OK?
So this is leading up to that.
It's sort of a similar thing.
So I thought for
the rest of the time
today, because I knew this
was going to end early,
I thought what I would
do is just switch gears
and talk about writing.
So normally when
I give a class, I
don't talk about
writing all that much.
I talk about the
technical stuff.
But it turns out writing is
actually a huge part of what
scientists do and engineers do
and whether or not you end up
with an academic job
or a job in industry
or working for government,
no matter where you are,
you are going to
have to write things.
And the better you write, the
better off you're going to be.
So I made copies
of this brochure
and I have a few little slides.
And you're going to have
to write up your project
report for me, and I thought
it might be helpful to just go
through this little brochure.
So I'm not going to
write stuff on the board.
Everything is pretty
much in this brochure,
but I thought I'd just
walk you through some
of the main parts of it.
Oh, did you get one?
Here, have one.
So you might want to think about
this when you're writing up
your project report
for this class,
but this really
is, it's general.
It's really for any time
you have to write something.
This is helpful.
So Mike Ashby put this together.
And as I mentioned, he's done
a lot of scientific writing
and especially in material
science and engineering.
He also makes paintings.
This is one of Mike's
little paintings
of him writing a paper.
And what I was going to do
is just walk through it.
So there's just a few
figures, and mostly it's text,
but let me go through
some of the figures.
So I'm going to just turn
to what's page three, OK?
So one of the things
that he says to start,
and I think this
makes a lot of sense,
is that you can think of
writing a paper the same way you
can think about designing
something in engineering.
So when you think
about design, there's
different stages
of design, right?
There's a conceptual design,
where you just decide roughly
what the thing's going to be.
There's embodiment,
where you work out
a lot of the more details.
You design one version of it.
And then there's the
detailed design, where
you do all the fine-tuning.
You do all the
final design things.
And before you really
start your design,
if you were going to design
an engineering thing,
you would first of all think
about what's the market.
And if you're writing, the
market is your readers.
And so when you think about
what you're going to write,
you have to think about
who's going to read it.
And it's the same thing
when I give a talk.
When I give a talk, before I
make a single PowerPoint slide,
the first thing I think
about is who am I talking to
and what do they already know?
What's the audience?
What are they looking
to get out of the talk?
What am I trying to
convey in the talk?
And the writing
is the same thing.
You have to think
about your audience.
So for instance, I
have technical talks.
Obviously, I go give
technical talks at meetings,
but I do other
sorts of talks too.
I've got the woodpecker talk.
I go give the woodpecker
talk at the Mass Audubon.
And people come to
listen to that talk who
are interested in birds
but they're not engineers.
So when I do that
talk, I have to make it
so somebody could understand
it who's intelligent
but they're not
necessarily an engineer.
So I give a different
kind of talk
when I do that than when I
give an engineering talk.
And I got invited
to a student dinner.
I'm going out to somewhere
with some students on Friday.
I'm going to give that how
I became a professor talk,
and when I do the how I
became a professor talk,
it's more general, and so it's
a different audience that I'm
thinking about.
And in some ways,
when I do these talks,
it can be the same
group of people,
but depending on what
I'm talking about,
the way they look at
it is different, OK?
So the market thing is
something to think about.
So if you're writing
a thesis, your market
is your PhD committee, who's
going to read the thesis
and examine you on the thesis.
If you're writing
a paper, you've
got to think about
the market as being
other people in your
research field, some of who
are going to be the
reviewers, who are going to be
reading it and criticizing it.
If you're writing a general
popular science book,
it's a different
kind of audience.
If you're writing a
research proposal,
the audience is going to
be the funding agency.
Are they interested in what
you're talking about, but also
reviewers, who are
going to be deciding
whether or not to
give you the money
and what the criticisms are.
So you have to think
about who the market is.
So that's one thing.
And one thing that think about
in doing the writing-- you
know Mike and I have written
several books together,
and when I tell my neighbors
I've written books,
they somehow think--
their first idea is
that we start on
page one and we start
writing the book from
page one and then
we work our way
through to page 500.
And that's not how
we do it at all
and that's not how
I write papers.
That's not how most
people write papers.
You've got to think
about the big picture
and think about,
roughly, what goes where.
And then maybe
think about a draft
that gets the
scientific facts right.
You put the information
down, and then you
try to figure out about how do
you make the style really nice?
How to make it read well?
How do you make it
easy to understand?
How does one paragraph lead
into the next paragraph?
So it's an iterative thing.
It's not like you start
at page one or line one
and you just start writing.
So it's an iterative process,
the same as engineering design
is an iterative process.
If you were going to
design, I don't know,
a skateboard or something,
you wouldn't just
think you were going to make
one and that would be it.
That's how writing is, and
often, students don't see it
as this iterative thing.
OK, so that's that page there.
Let's see, I already
talked about market.
I think I have another
little slide about-- here's
another slide here
about markets.
So this is what I just said.
Who are the readers?
How are they going to use it?
So you've got to think
about who you're writing for
or if you're giving a talk,
who's going to look at that.
OK, now the next
phase is to make what
Mike calls a concept sheet.
I would just think of
this as an outline.
And I always make
some sort of outline
before I try to write anything.
And there's different
ways you can do that.
The thing that Mike's
got here and there's
a nice little figure
on page six, which
is what I've got up here, is
he takes a big piece of paper.
In Europe, it would
be known as the A3.
Here it would be known as
the eight and a half by 17.
You take a big piece of paper.
This stationery company
actually makes paper
with big blank space in
the middle and little note
space on the outside or you
could just use the back of it.
So you take a big
piece of paper and you
may think this is douffy,
but it actually helps.
So you take your
big piece of paper,
and you just make
boxes about each topic.
You're going to have
an introduction,
you're going to have
methods and materials,
a result section.
And you think about what should
go into each of those boxes.
And what you're
trying to do here
is think about the whole paper
and how it all fits together
and what goes where and what
are you going to include
and what are you not
going to include.
So people think about writing
as sitting at the keyboard
and typing, but
that's just the--
how when you get a
problem on a problem
set, you turn and crank, that's
the turning and cranking part.
The thoughtful part is
figuring out what to put in,
what to leave out,
what figures you want,
how you organize
the whole thing,
how you put it all together,
and this helps you do that.
And you can make this--
it's just for you.
It doesn't have to look great.
You can make this
messy if you want.
It doesn't really matter.
But it's good to have some sort
of an overview of how you want
to put the thing
together, and that's
what this stage helps you do.
So Mike's put other
little things here.
So see papers by
so-and-so and so-and-so.
So you've got an introduction.
You want to talk
about something.
You know there should be
some references go here.
Maybe you think there's
some extra references
you haven't got.
Maybe something in
the method, there's
some analogy you can use here.
Maybe you need a figure,
needs a good figure.
You don't have to
actually have the figure.
You just say I need a figure
and you have a vague idea what
the figure looks like.
Here there's some
discussion point.
Discuss this with collaborators,
Ed, all this stuff.
So you just put down roughly
what needs to go where
and you think about
the whole thing
and how it's all
going to fit together.
And then as you work through
it, it looks more like this.
So this would be on page seven.
And this is filled
in, and if fact,
this particular one, what
he's written down here
is the overview he made for
making this booklet, OK?
So the things
refer to this book.
So here's the introduction.
Here's the little chart we
went through and through,
the concept design, embodiment,
and detail, blah, blah, blah.
Here's the need,
the market need.
We just talked about that.
Here's the concept thing that
we we're just talking about now.
Then we're going to talk about
each of these different phases.
And his initials are
MFA, Michael F. Ashby.
Think out, that means
think about this more.
I haven't figured this out yet.
I need an example here,
all these kinds of things.
So this is the way he does it.
There's a couple of
other ways you can do it.
One way is to just make
a bullet outline, that's
typically what I do.
You know you're going
to have an introduction,
these different headings.
And you might put in
the bullet outline
these same sorts of things,
like I need this figure
or we need to get
one more set of data
or I need to look
up this reference.
So it doesn't have
to be finished,
but it's a thing that tells
you what have you got,
what do you need to do to
make it all come together.
So that's one way to do it.
Another way to do it is
by thinking about what
figures you want in the paper.
So some people, before
they write any words,
they say, well, I know I
want to have these figures,
and then they build the
words around the figures.
And they can even sketch
out what the figures are.
Some people even start before
they start the project,
they say what kind
of figures do I
want at the end of the project?
And they don't know if the data
is going to do this or that.
They don't know which way
the data is going to go,
but they say I want
to have a plot of one
thing versus another thing.
Oh, you're looking
like this is not OK?
AUDIENCE: No.
LORNA GIBSON: No?
OK, yeah, some people do this.
So even when you're
ready to write,
you could say to yourself,
well, in the methods,
do I need a figure that's a
schematic of some apparatus?
In the results, how am I
going to present the results
in the discussion?
Do we need some
other kind of figure?
So if you have a
set of figures, you
can work the text
around those figures.
So that's another
way to do this.
So those are just three
options, but all of them
have in common that you
think about the whole paper
and how it all fits
together and what
goes where and what
do you have already
and what else do
you need to get, OK?
So that's that.
And then what I
was going to do--
I think that's probably the
last figure that's-- yeah, OK.
So there's just this
little thing here.
So what I was going to do
is just talk about some
of the other things in
this little booklet that
work through each of these
stages of the writing.
So that's the concept,
and then the next phase
would be what's
called the embodiment,
if you think of the
design language,
and that would be
the first draft.
And I think most people find
the most difficult thing is
to write the first draft.
I mean, I find that the hardest.
Once you've got
something, editing it
is relatively straightforward.
You go, oh, this piece
should go over there
or there's something missing.
But getting the first draft
down is the hardest thing.
And one of the
things-- it's like when
I talked about
writing the book, you
don't write the draft
sequentially either.
I typically tell students
to start with the materials
and methods because that's
the most straightforward
and it's the easiest to write.
There's not a whole lot of
mystery to how you actually did
something you've already done.
So I tell people don't write
the introduction first.
That's a bad idea because
it's actually often not
so easy to write
the introduction.
So I tell people to write the
materials and methods first.
Write the result section
because you've got your results
and you know what the
results are going to be.
So those are the
two easiest things.
And often, I think,
what people find
is if they find it hard to write
it's because they don't know
what they want to write or they
haven't thought things through.
They haven't got their
thoughts together.
And if you've got
your thoughts, if you
know what you want to say, then
the writing becomes easier.
So one of the pieces
of advice Mike
gave me, and it's
in this booklet too,
is in the first draft
what you should try to do
is just get the facts down.
Just get the information
down and don't
worry about if it
doesn't sound quite right
or if this sentence doesn't
lead into that sentence.
Don't worry about the
style of it at all.
Just try to get the facts down.
Just try to get the
information down.
And once you've
got the information
and you've got some kind
of framework-- I'm not
saying that you don't want
to make the style good,
you do, but you don't need
to do that the first thing.
The first thing is just
to get the facts down,
and then you can
edit it later on.
It's more of this
iterative process.
OK, so the first draft,
the most important thing
is just to get the facts down.
Then, I'm not going to
read all of these things
because you can just
read them yourself,
but I'll just comment
on a few things.
So one thing he's got--
I'm on page eight now,
is the abstract.
So the abstract
should be concise.
It should be fairly
short and you
want to tell people why
you're doing what you're
doing, what you did,
what the key result is,
and what the conclusions are.
So it can be pretty short.
There's a section
on the introduction.
You can just read that.
Let's see here.
Yeah, I think, you can read
yourself these other things.
I don't want to go
through the whole thing.
All right, so that's that.
OK, so you get to the
end of the first draft,
there's a little
section on figures here.
Let me just make some
comments on that.
People who are busy
and may not want
to read every word
that you've written
will look at the figures, and
they'll look at the figures
to make some judgment about
does this look useful?
Does this look like
you've got something
I want to spend more time on?
So it's important to make the
figures easily understandable
and to be fairly self-contained.
So you want to make
the figures clear.
You don't want to have
too much information on it
so that people can't
follow what's going on,
and you want them to
illustrate the points
that you're trying to make.
So the figures are
very important.
And then when you've got
the first draft finished,
the next step, which I
find tremendously useful
and students often don't
get that this is a step.
The next step is
you put it somewhere
and you don't do anything
with it for a while.
And this is why it's
important not to write it up
at the last second.
Because there's something
about, you work on something,
you put it to one
side, you don't do it.
You just leave it and
you go do something else.
And then when you come back
to it, all of a sudden,
you see things that you didn't
see the first time through.
So the next step is you
just put it to one side
for a couple days.
But you can only do
that step for a class
if you started before the
night before it's due, OK?
So that's why you
have to start earlier.
That's why I'm telling
you this now, OK?
So you put it aside and then
you go have a cup of coffee.
You see there's
several cups of coffee
that Mike has happily
drawn for us here.
OK, then the next
part of this is
all about grammar and
sentence structure.
I'm not going to go over that.
You can read all that yourself.
But there is one amusing
thing I want to tell you
because there's a cute story.
I'm on page 16 now.
There's a thing about spelling.
Mike is a terrible speller.
When I was his student,
he used to-- there
were no word processors.
And we used to write things
and he would write things
and I would say, I
can't read your writing.
And he says, ah, well, I
make up for my bad spelling
with my bad writing.
So I couldn't tell if he
had spelled something right.
The other thing we
found was that, we
wrote the cellular solid
book, the first edition
was in the 1980s.
And I grew up in Canada,
then I lived in England,
then I moved here.
He grew up in Australia,
then he moved to England,
then he moved to the States
then he moved back to England.
And words that end, that
we spell I-Z-E, like
normalized, like
normalized variables.
They're I-Z-E here.
In England, they're all I-S-E.
OK, and then some of
the words, it turns out,
Canadians spell with an
I-Z-E and some with I-S-E.
So anyway, we wrote the
entire fricking book.
We were almost ready
to send it off,
and we have all those graphs
where the axes are normalized,
and we must have used the word
normalized like 100 times,
and we realized half the
time we had spelled it I-S-E
and half the time we
had spelled it I-Z-E.
And then we had to go back and
find them all and fix it all.
So anyway, that's just our
little story about spelling.
OK, there's a thing
about punctuation.
You can read that.
That's kind of boring.
I wanted to move on to
the bit about style,
because style is important too.
And people remember papers
that are well written.
Obviously, papers that have
valuable scientific information
are memorable too, but
if it's well-written,
it's more memorable, and the
style really is important.
And it's the same
with giving a talk.
You can convey the
same information,
but if you don't have it
presented in a clear way,
people aren't going
to remember it.
So the first rule--
so I'm on page 20.
The first rule,
now, is to be clear.
And being clear, it doesn't mean
having long-winded sentences
with lots of jargon.
It really just means make
it short, make it concise,
make it clear what
you want to say.
So Mike has several
examples here
of headlines from
the newspapers, which
were not clear.
So I'll just read these out
because I find them amusing.
"Red Tape Holds Up New Bridge."
So, OK, maybe the red tape
temporally held it up, but not
spatially held it up.
OK, and then here's another
one. "Something Went
Wrong in Jet Crash,
Expert Says."
In fact, you hear this all
the time on the news now.
Obviously, something went wrong.
You don't have to be an
engineer to figure out something
went wrong in a jet crash.
Then, "Chef Throws Heart In
To Help Feed the Hungry."
OK, well, maybe that's
a little too much.
This is my favorite one,
"Prostitutes Appeal to Pope."
OK, there's different
ways you can appeal.
You don't have to appeal
to the Pope in that way.
And then, "Panda Mating
Fails, Vet Takes Over."
I don't think the vet really
took over with the mating,
but you know what they mean.
OK, so one thing is clarity.
Another point is don't waffle.
You want things to be
concise and get to the point.
So he's got this
example here from what
he cites as a well-known but
anonymous materials text.
"The selection of
the proper material
is a key step in
the design process,
because it is the
crucial decision that
links computer
calculations and the lines
on an engineering drawing with
a real or working design."
But what does it say?
It says material
selection is important.
So don't say something
in some long-winded way
that you could say
in a short way.
OK, let's see.
So let me move on
to the next page.
The next step that I-- let
me emphasize one more time,
is 8.5, revise and rewrite.
So writing really is iterative.
Those books that you've seen
that Mike and I have written,
I cannot tell you how many
drafts of each chapter we went
through over and
over and over again.
So to make it good, you have
to do it over and over again.
OK, there's that.
Let me see.
Is there anything
else I have here?
Ah, here's a couple things
that are not so obvious.
So one is, for each
paragraph you should
have a good first sentence.
You should tell the
reader something
they don't already know.
So there's some examples here,
and you can read through them.
But it is really helpful
for each paragraph
to have a good opening sentence.
Another thing is at the
end of the paragraph
it's good if there's a sentence
that links it to the next one.
So it hints at what the next
paragraph's going to be about,
so it leads the
reader through it,
and it is a logical progression.
So an opening sentence
for the paragraph
and the final
sentence, you might
want to look at in a
bit more gory detail.
OK, and then there are some
references at the very back,
at page 25.
And I brought a couple of books
in that I have found helpful.
So you may have seen these.
One is called The
Elements of Style
and this is by Strunk and
White, so William Strunk, Jr.
and EB White.
You guys know EB White,
Charlotte's Web, same guy.
He's written this small, small,
not too long to have a look at
book about style.
So there's some rules of
usage, which is grammar stuff,
but there's principles
of composition
and there's a chapter called
"An Approach to Style."
And so here's some
of the headings.
Place yourself in
the background.
Write in a way that
comes naturally.
Work from a suitable design.
These people are not engineers,
but they're saying work
from a suitable design.
It's like that concept thing.
Revise and rewrite,
did I mention that,
revise and rewrite?
Do not overwrite.
Don't make it too complicated.
Avoid the use of qualifiers.
If you say something's very
stiff, what does that mean?
You can just say it's stiff.
You don't have to
say it's very stiff.
Very compared to what?
Let's see.
Use orthodox spelling, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
Avoid fancy words.
OK, be clear, all
this kind of stuff.
So Strunk and White
is old but good.
And then, there's this
book here by Bill Bryson.
Bryson's Dictionary
of Troublesome Words.
So this is, it is
like a dictionary.
It goes by letter and
has different words,
but it talks about
how people sometimes
use a word thinking it means
one thing when it doesn't, it
actually means something else.
And so it's just words
that people use commonly
that they sometimes confuse
with what they really mean.
So it's a very handy thing too.
Do you know Bill Bryson?
Very funny travel writer.
If you ever go somewhere
that Bill Bryson has been you
should get the book he's
written about it because he's
very funny.
OK, so I think that's it.
Oh, and then, I think, the
very end of this booklet
has some examples of good
writing and bad writing.
So you can have a
look at that too.
All right, so are we good
on how to write a paper?
Do you have questions
on how to write?
Writing is important.
So I have one more
writing story.
So when I first got this job at
MIT, I was living in Arlington,
and my mom comes to
visit me from Toronto.
And I'm work, work, work,
work, working, working,
and my mom says to
me, she says, my, you
spend a lot of
your life writing.
I'm like, Mom, that's
what I get paid to do.
I get paid to write.
Like she always
thought I was should
be spending maybe
30 hours a week
lecturing or
something like that.
Like she, well,
you're a teacher.
You only teach three hours
a week, what is this?
I'm like, I write, Mom.
That's what I do.
So anyways, so
writing is important
and giving presentations
is important.
And no matter what
you end up doing,
you're going to end up having
to do those two things.
And if you do it well, it's
going to make your life better,
and if you do it badly, you're
not going to be so good.
So that's my message.
So I'm going to
stop there because I
haven't got the
next lecture ready,
and I can start that on Monday.
So Monday we'll do the
cell mechanic stuff.
And then let me just-- because
we're getting ridiculously
close to the end of term.
Like four weeks from
today is the last test.
I know, it's shocking.
So there's one lecture
on cell mechanics,
and then there's some more
engineering applications
of foam.
I'm going to talk about energy
absorption in foams and foams
in sandwich panels,
that kind of stuff.
And then, we're going to talk
about some natural materials
again.
We're going to talk about
natural structures, so
like natural sandwich panels
and natural cylindrical shells
with foamy cores.
So I've got lots
of nature things
at the last part of the
course, and you know
how I like those nature things.
So there you have it.
Bob's your uncle, as
my mother would say.
You know what Bob's
your uncle is?
Bob's your uncle is
an English expression.
It just means there you have it.
There you have it.